we spent three days in hospital watching
him die essentially terrific
killed after an unprovoked attack on the
street Rachel's brother Paul died after
he was assaulted in 2020. he went out
behind him punched him to the ground
Paul flew off his feet and hit the
ground the banking Executives killer
Stephen Allen will likely serve little
over a year for manslaughter Rachel and
her family are appealing and want a
review of guidelines
how can someone rehabilitate in a year
they can't we all know that prisons are
overstretched and resources are
stretched he's not going to get any any
kind of support in prison in a year
and then he'll be out in the community
it's it's sickening the sense of levels
are terrible and they are deterrent at
all Maxine understands that sense of
Injustice she set up a charity after her
son Christian died nine months after a
one-punch attack in a nightclub the man
who assaulted him served less than a
year for Grievous bodily harm oh what a
mirror what Australia do with an
Australia the accompanied long and hard
but they have achieved 15 years for one
punch assault I am that is just for the
assault if they die it's 25 years 25
years that would make a difference to
you wouldn't it on the other side
another view Jacob killed a man with one
punch over a decade ago jailed for 30
months serving 14 after admitting
manslaughter a life for a life
an eye for an eye
leads you down a very dark and sleep
slope steep slope where nobody changes
and everybody
thinks they have the moral High Ground
until they make a mistake and then they
you know never redeemable again
Edward Henry King's Council says the
sentencing guidelines while an imperfect
system do work every single life is
innately precious
no sentence is going to adequately
reflect that but would it not be better
that a person who has made a ghastly
mistake and they have recognized that
and they have pleaded guilty to man's
daughter
would it not be better than to sentence
them on the basis that they did not
intend to kill
Rachel lost her other brother Simon
months after Paul's death himself
devastated by grief a family awaiting
now a possible appeal for them Justice
is yet to be served Adele Robinson Sky
News